from beloved Avengers to the Vigilantes
of the arrowverse there have been a ton
of heartbreaking hero deaths since the
year 2000. in 2005 there was a lot of
hype leading up to the DC Comics event
Infinite Crisis as a long-awaited sequel
to The Beloved crisis on infinite Earths
there was certainly a lot that the Jeff
John's Penn series had to live up to in
the one shot countdown to Infinite
Crisis Johns and his team set the stage
for the massive inter-company crossover
centering on a story led by the often
overlooked Justice League member Blue
Beetle not to be confused with his
successor Jaime Reyes Ted core doesn't
have superpowers and instead uses his
wealth to build his own equipment like
Batman but after cord loses his fortune
he tracks down the thief to checkmate's
base in Switzerland where he's
confronted by his one-time Ally Maxwell
Lord Lord who had previously worked with
cord as a member of the Justice League
International offers the hero a chance
to join him in his mission to wipe
metahumans and superheroes off the map
cord declines but Lord is unwilling to
let Blue Beetle walk free shooting him
in the head and killing him instantly
unlike most Comic Book Heroes Ted cord
remain dead for a long time with Jaime
Reyes taking the mantle of Blue Beetle
from the Fallen Hero although cord is
Alive and Well now following a
company-wide reboot his brutal death was
beyond shocking at the time and it had
major ramifications throughout the DC
Universe
after two incredibly successful X-Men
films director Brian Singer bowed out of
the third installment to take on
Superman Returns and he took actor James
Marsden with him the results were pretty
disastrous for X-Men the Last Stand as
Marsden Cyclops ended up essentially
written out of the trilogy's end after
Gene gray is resurrected as the Phoenix
following her demise at the end of X2
she pulls Scott into a seductive Embrace
and kills him off screen while Cyclops
had been a main cast member for the
previous two features and the field
leader of the team he doesn't even suit
up in the Last Stand following his death
Wolverine and storm takeover leadership
duties as they battle against the now
villainous Jean Gray to stop her from
ending all human and mutant life
Wolverine is forced to kill Gene in a
shot that mimicked her second comic book
deaths a few years prior
save me
needless to say Scott and Jean end up
together again in the end just six feet
underground after Wolverine helps change
the timeline in X-Men Days of Future
Past Scott and Jean appear alive again
in the revised reality as the events of
the Last Stand never happened while
there is a dark Phoenix story in this
timeline the critically penned 2019 film
Scott makes it out alive from that one
by the time Infinite Crisis began the
entire DC Universe was in flux much like
the first crisis event this limited
series rocked the world of DC Comics and
served to rewrite the timeline once more
restoring old Origins and worlds in the
process along the way the villainous
Superboy Prime hopes to wipe out the
universe thankfully Superboy the clone
of both Superman and Lex Luthor who goes
by the names con L and Connor Kent
arrives just in time to save the day
sadly things don't go exactly as planned
a host of Heroes including two Supermen
Batman Wonder Woman and their Protege
arrive too late to save Superboy and the
boy of Steel dies of his injuries after
fending off Prime from destroying the
world although Superboy isn't able to
stop the Tyrant on his own he gives his
fellow Heroes the final push they need
to save the Multiverse Superboy would
remain dead for a long time in the DC
timeline though he'd be resurrected only
three years later in real world time
after his death Conor body is placed in
a holding chamber for one thousand years
before being reborn in the futuristic
world of the Legion of Superheroes at
the end of Marvel's Civil War the comic
book not the movie Captain America
surrenders to Shield to end the conflict
between superheroes hoping to make
amends with Iron Man and keep his fellow
resistors out of prison he believes that
the only way to truly end this conflict
is to give himself up as he's taken into
custody cap is shockingly assassinated
on the steps of the courthouse by
crossbones under the orders of the Red
Skull unsurprisingly though there turns
out to be a conspiracy of foot after the
death of Steve Rogers his former partner
and reformed assassin Bucky Barnes picks
up the shield working alongside the
Avengers and caps modern day sidekick
Falcon to discover the truth behind
Steve's assassination years later an ed
brubaker's follow-up Captain America
Reborn the entire truth is revealed Red
Skull had brainwashed Sharon Carter into
shooting him on the steps sending his
Consciousness forward and backward
throughout time eventually like most
deceased Comic Book Heroes Steve was
restored reclaiming the mantle of
Captain America as Bucky turns to his
role as the Winter Soldier still the
Marvel Universe wasn't the same without
Captain America and While others made on
the red white and blue for a while there
will never be another Steve Rogers
speaking of Heroes who died only to find
themselves scattered through time writer
Grant Morrison killed off The Dark
Knight himself in the 2008 event series
final crisis meant to be the end of the
crisis Trilogy final crisis saw Darkseid
fight to claim ownership over the DC
Universe even extending his reach Beyond
just one world leading up to final
crisis Morrison had penned the Batman
rip story arc which deconstructed the
hero's vast comic book history and
nearly killed him in the process however
Batman's actual death would occur in
final crisis after he mortally wounded
Darkseid Batman's comic book death was
shocking to all who witnessed it and the
build-up towards it was impressive
following Wayne's demise his Protege
Dick Grayson adopts the cape and Cowell
as his own carrying on his mentor's
legacy for nearly two years of course
Batman could never stay dead but this
shocking conclusion that saw the end of
The Dark Knight rippled throughout the
comic book and Real Worlds alike as it
turns out after Darkseid had used his
Omega beams on Batman The Dark Knight
was sent through the DCU timeline as he
slowly regained his memories of his life
as Bruce Wayne this is chronicled in
Morrison's limited series Batman The
Return of Bruce Wayne which eventually
restores our hero to his rightful place
in Gotham whenever a direct comic book
adaptation is brought to the screen
chances are that we already know how
it's going to end but even if we know
what's coming the ending can still be
just as shocking if it's done right this
is certainly true with Zack Snyder's
adaptation of the iconic graphic novel
Watchmen although longtime fans of the
Alan Moore story knew exactly how the
film would end that didn't make the
finale of Snyder's version any less
impactful after it's revealed that
Ozymandias has perpetrated a nuclear
attack on the world's biggest cities
framing Dr Manhattan in the process the
former team decides that they must allow
the near omniscient being to take the
fall to maintain World Peace well except
for Rorschach who believes that the
world has a right to know never
compromise
face of Armageddon Rorschach refuses to
back down choosing to die for his
principles at Dr Manhattan's hand rather
than live a lie The Moody anti-hero is
vaporized but his words Remain the end
of Watchmen reveals that rorschach's
journal containing information about
ozymandias's plan has been leaked to the
press the truth lives on for those who
choose to listen to it before the
arrowverse stretched across multiple
time slots on the CW many of DC's finest
found themselves in Smallville over the
course of 10 seasons this Superman
origin story Dove deep into the comics
continuity introducing Clark to Heroes
like Cyborg and Aquaman years before
their big screen debuts not every hero
would make it through the series end to
establish the Justice League though case
in point Carter Hall the hero known to
the world as Hawkman in the episode
aptly titled Icarus the villain Darkseid
uses his influence on the people of
metropolis to change their perception of
vigilance 20s this includes the U.S army
General Slade Wilson who makes it his
sworn duty to detain and destroy the
world's greatest heroes after Lois Lane
uncovers Wilson's plan he threatens her
life at gunpoint but she's saved by
Hawkman at the last second as Hawkman
battles Slade a gas explosion blows out
the room forcing the winged hero to
catch Lois before she's consumed by
Flames Hawkman manages to get Clark's
fiancee out safely but it's at the cost
of his own life as Carter dies in his
friend's arms he Embraces his next
adventure and is hopeful that he'll be
reunited with his wife in their next
life
hey
pro at dying remember the episode ends
on a somber note with the Leaguers
burying their colleague as his sacrifice
is honored by all no superhero's death
has been the topic of such fiery debate
as was Darwin's in 2011's X-Men first
Class a mutant with an ability called
reactive Evolution Darwin embodies his
namesake by being able to adapt to just
about anything in the comics Darwin is a
strange almost alien-like mutant who's
been around since the early 21st century
though in the film much like his fellow
mutants beast and Mystique he looks
mostly human when he wants to upon an
attack from Sebastian Shaw and his
hellfire club the newly formed X-Men are
faced with a choice join Shaw and
abandon their values or stand with
Professor X and Magneto on the side of
Justice well with just one exception the
X-Men make the right choice even if it
has deadly consequences
[Music]
Unfortunately The Versatile mutant isn't
able to survive Shaw's killing blow
Eddie gethighi who portrayed Darwin
wasn't exactly pleased with his
character's fate he told comicbook.com I
thought that was a huge Miss killing
Darwin and I think Darwin does deserve
Redemption most fans agree and consider
the character's premature death a stain
on an otherwise solid superhero movie
when the X-Men make their way to the MCU
perhaps kategy could get the opportunity
to reprise his role and show off
Darwin's true potential it's one thing
to kill off a comic book hero chances
are they'll come back at some point it's
another thing to kill off your most
popular character twice in the span of
two years that's right in case you
forgot Marvel Comics killed off Peter
Parker the hero most commonly known as
Spider-Man on two separate occasions in
the early 2010s first was the Ultimate
Spider-Man series written by Brian
Michael Bendis in June 2011 which was
followed by Dan slots Amazing Spider-Man
run in December 2012. for over a decade
the modern teenage reinterpretation of
Peter Parker reigned in Ultimate
Spider-Man a highly acclaimed series
that often flipped the Spider-Man Mythos
on its head however in the death of
Spider-Man Arc Peter manages to save his
Aunt May from the Green Goblin in a
battle that costs him his life while
this paved the way for the era of Miles
Morales it was no less a blow to see
this version of Spidey go at least for a
few years we were likewise heartbroken
when the mainstream Peter Parker was
killed off in the dying wish storyline
which ended with a dying Doctor Octopus
switching bodies with Spider-Man as
Peter laid dying Doc Ock took on the
mantle of superior Spider-Man and vowed
to honor Peter's Legacy although this
version of Peter would eventually return
as well dying wish was certainly a tough
Arc to get through when Firestorm the
nuclear man was introduced in the very
first season of the flesh fans were
excited at the possibilities of other
super-powered heroes in the arrowverse
at the time only the flash himself and a
few others had any special abilities but
the universe would expand further from
there when Ronnie Raymond and Dr Martin
Stein merged into the conjoined
transmuted being called Firestorm
they're able to use their powers to Aid
their friends and save the universe from
destruction after having just gotten
married to Dr Caitlin snow Robbie's
forced to merge with Stein once again in
order to help the flash save Central
City from a singularity tragically this
costs Robbie his life and while he saves
Stein and the rest of the world he and
Caitlyn never make it to their honeymoon
a villainous version of Robbie known as
Death Storm appears on Earth too but
he's nothing like the real Robbie and he
dies after getting stabbed in the back
by his boss marnstein eventually
sacrifices himself for his new partner
Jax thus ending Firestorm forever
firestorms multiple deaths are hard to
watch but being a hero means being
willing to make the ultimate sacrifice
after years of implying that Oliver
Queen and Dina Laura Lance were meant to
be together by the show's end Arrow
threw us a curveball and killed off
Laurel in the show's fourth season at
the hands of antagonist Damien dark
after her sister's death the year prior
Laurel had taken up the identity of
Black Canary in her memory eventually
laying down her very life for her home
it's worth noting that this was the time
during the show's run when fans were
debating whether Oliver should end up
with Laurel like in the DC Comics or
with newcomer Felicity smoke naturally
Laurel's stats sort of settled the
debate
I hope you find your way back to her in
fact Laurel's death only pushes team
Arrow even more to defeat Dark and
reclaim their City it was a bit of a
bummer though and it was a creative
choice that was certainly met with some
criticism while Laurel remains six feet
under her Earth 2 doppelganger
eventually makes her way to Star City
where she reforms from her criminal ways
and joins team Arrow even when Oliver is
given Supernatural power and the
opportunity to reverse death he keeps
Laurel's sacrifice intact nice one Ollie
of all the movies in the DC extended
Universe none were more controversial
among audiences at the time of release
than Batman v Superman dawn of Justice
whether you loved Zack Snyder's attempt
to merge multiple comic book story lines
together or you hated the conflict
between the world's finest Duo there's
no doubt that Superman's ultimate
sacrifice was both unexpected and pretty
hard to watch after making amends with
Batman the Man of Steel Works alongside
the Caped Crusader and newcomer Wonder
Woman to battle the Kryptonian
Abomination doomsday as this Trinity of
Heroes fends off Lex Luthor's brainless
monster Superman gets the chance to use
Batman's Kryptonite pointed spear to
pierce its heart but doomsday also
impales Superman during the struggle
killing the Man of Steel after Batman
and Wonder Woman retrieve his body Lois
Lane holds his lifeless corpse which is
especially devastating considering that
Clark was about to propose of course
Henry cavill's Superman is resurrected
in both versions of Justice League to
help the Bachelor Heroes against
darkseid's forces but had Batman v
Superman been the end to Snyder's Canon
it would have finished on a truly sour
note thankfully just like in the comics
Superman Returns from the dead just in
the nick of time
for a while Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and
Patrick Stewart's Professor X were the
longest running live-action Superheroes
having played the characters for nearly
20 years James mangold's Logan put an
end to all that well until more recent
MCU outings officially concluding the
X-Men Canon with a western inspired
finale unlike anything else that Marvel
has ever released like most Wolverine
stories this one isn't for the faint of
heart but it's still an incredible tale
with an ending we can't quite get over
after taking his daughter Laura across
the border into Canada losing his own
surrogate father along the way Logan is
forced to defend a group of young
mutants as reavers arrive to take them
into captivity using the last of his
strength Logan fends off a younger clone
of himself before Laura delivers the
final blow as the last X-Men dies in his
daughter's arms he uses his final words
to remind her that she has control over
her own destiny
don't be hard damage
this end of an era brought plenty of
folks to Tears by the time the Johnny
Cash scored credits rolled although some
version of Wolverine played by Jackman
is set to appear in the upcoming
Deadpool 3. this time in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe for many his story
truly ended in Logan to mention everyone
who died in Avengers Infinity War would
take a lot longer than we have time for
here but there are a few characters
whose deaths have been a bit more
permanent since they weren't restored in
Avengers end game among them are the
reformed Loki the Android vision and the
Guardians of the Galaxy member Gamora in
the battle against Thanos both Loki and
vision sacrificed themselves to save the
universe from the Mad Titans schemes
while their deaths are tough to watch
especially after everything these
characters had gone through it's
gamora's death that's the most tragic
just as she and Peter Quill had finally
commenced their relationship Thanos took
that all away in a moment that seemed
just as painful for him as a was for us
though everyone who died in Infinity War
has made their way back to the MCU in
some capacity since including variants
of Loki vision and Gamora these
initially well-developed versions of
these characters haven't been seen since
in fact neither Star-Lord nor Scarlet
Witch have really gotten over their
Lover's deaths with the latter handling
it particularly poorly at least Thor
seems to be taking the loss of his
brother relatively okay
although most of the deaths in Avengers
Infinity War were undone by endgame's
finale those who met their demise in the
fourth Avengers flick weren't so lucky
before the world was saved and before
she got her own Solo movie Black Widow
gave her life for the Salvation of the
universe even as all her friends and
family were restored poor Natasha never
got to reunite with those she loved most
in the world even after years of
fighting the good fight as Black Widow
and Hawkeye are sent to vormir the Red
Skull reveals that only one of them will
make it out of their alive if they want
to return with the Soul Stone but our
heroes don't agree on which of them
should be the one to make the ultimate
sacrifice
years I've been trying one thing get to
write
to write no don't you get all decent on
me now as Natasha and Clint battle it
out to decide who will sacrifice
themselves Black Widow comes out on top
jumping out of Hawkeye's grasp and
falling down to the ground with her
death The Avengers are able to reunite
the Infinity Stones and reverse thanos's
original snap restoring the world's
population while black widow's first
solo film was released after her death
and end game the character's demise has
been decidedly final while her sacrifice
has been largely overshadowed by that of
a certain metal based hero it has still
made an unforgettable impact on the MCU
at Large
as the hero who started it all Robert
Downey Jr's Iron Man is easily the most
recognizable face in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe beginning with 2008's
Iron Man Downey Jr played Tony Stark for
over a decade before Avengers end game
premiered all in all Stark appeared in
10 movies across the MCU before his
passing at the end of end game after
infinity War Iron Man like everyone else
was left defeated with little hope for
the future then he had a daughter and
his family became his sole priority so
when the Avengers come up with a plan to
reverse thanos's snap it's no wonder
that Stark is leery of messing all of
that up however after the Avengers
managed to recover everyone who had been
turned to dust Thanos arrives to reclaim
the Infinity Stones and remake the world
in his own image he's stopped by Stark
who uses the stones to make the ultimate
sacrifice as Iron Man uses the stones to
erase Thanos in his forces they drain
the life out of him thankfully most of
his loved ones including his best friend
his Protege Peter Parker and his wife
pepper are there to see him off pretty
much everyone in the Avengers can be
seen at Tony's funeral soon after
needless to say Iron Man's death led to
plenty of Misty Eyes in the theater
and again that's the hero gig part of
the journey is the end
starting a greater Universe while Iron
Man launched the MCU the Stephen Amell
lead Arrow began the CW's DC Comics
inspired arrowverse in 2012. what
started as a grounded attempt to retell
the Green Arrow Legend became the
Bedrock for a series of connected
superhero shows bringing the heroes of
DC Comics to life on the small screen as
Oliver Queen developed from a
bloodthirsty vigilante to the leader of
a group of Heroes he became willing to
lay down his life for the sake of the
universe after a whole season of
foreshadowing Oliver confronts his own
mortality and the crisis of infinite
Earth's crossover event this much-hyped
storyline United the heroes from Arrow
of The Flash Supergirl Batwoman and DC's
Legends of tomorrow with those from
other worlds including Lucifer
Smallville and Superman Returns during
his efforts to save his friends and 1
billion innocent lives Oliver is killed
by Shadow Demons only to be resurrected
later as the spirit of Vengeance known
as the specter as the Specter Oliver
lays his life down a second time to stop
the world killing anti-monitor and
restore the Multiverse in the year 2040
Oliver reunites with his wife Felicity
in the afterlife a well-deserved end to
such a pivotal character
from the very first episode of The Flash
it's teased that just like his comic
book counterpart Barry Allen will die in
the forthcoming crisis while this
ultimately proves true it doesn't happen
in the way many expect it to instead of
the Grant Gustin flash meetings and
during the crisis on infinite Earths The
Flash from the short-lived 1990s The
Flash series played by John Wesley's
ship gives up his life for the universe
in a scene that perfectly mirrors Barry
Allen's comic book demise fans of the
original 90s series rejoiced when ship
returned as the original live-action
Barry Allen in the arrow vs elseworld's
crossover back in 2018 but his return
was short-lived ship had previously
played Barry's father Henry Allen on the
flash as well as the Earth 3 variant Jay
Garrick but his second return as the
original Berry is particularly
heartbreaking as gustin's Barry says
goodbye to his best friends he's about
to fulfill his Destiny only for ships
flash to step into the antimatter Cannon
instead tearing him apart novu said the
flash must die in crisis he never said
which one after years of fear that Barry
Allen might die on the flash these
spheres were ultimately realized in the
earth 90 Flash's demise but even if it
isn't guston's flash who sacrifices
himself the death of ship Splash is one
of the most tear-jerking moments from
the highly anticipated five-part Mega
crossover
if the death of a fictional hero is
tragic then the death of a real-life one
is even more so after the return of
Chadwick boseman's Black Panther in
Avengers end game fans were ecstatic
about the possibility of a follow-up to
the highly acclaimed 2018 black panther
film with Bozeman in the title role
unfortunately Bozeman died of colon
cancer in 2020 which drastically changed
black panther wakanda forever before the
film even began production after
Bozeman's death Marvel Studios refused
to recast King t'challa instead opting
to kill off the character by way of a
mysterious illness in the sequel of
course this happens off screen and plays
a huge role in the events of wakanda
forever namely in Suri's journey toward
becoming the New Black Panther and her
brother's honor but that's not the only
way that t'challa's memory is carried on
in the sequel It's also revealed that
his love interests Nakia had his son
during the blip whom she'd been raising
in secret
my name is Prince t'challa son of King
t'chella while the original black
panther may not live on in the MCU it's
reassuring to know that others continue
to carry on his name although Bozeman
and by extension t'challa himself may be
gone his legacy lives on
thank you
foreign